hello and welcome to this video playing
or like one for four let's see what
would like us playing Sicilian okay well
no 2,400 feels terrible really
oh my god but the last game some I
played were really quite awful so it's
well deserved
yeah I got a good watch central control
a black is also fine you can go b5 and
Bishop e7 and this is quite okay
surprised that you already takes I mean
not it's not terrible or anything but
still oh okay
it's more expecting something something
with with d5 yeah I was I'm giving up
the bishop here which is normally not
done but I wasn't I wasn't certain that
I have to move it like ten billion times
here the pieces that I still have are
quite okay I think okay is he ever going
for a five in the one one that like a
million times at proven $95
maybe it's going night b6 or something
queen bee ate probably so this Bishop is
really not doing much there I want to
watch over b6 and now what's the next
plan night
okay just straight stuff night over to
f5 maybe
ninety-two be 385 mean it's not
fantastic or anything but
okay just trades everything let's see
okay bishop coming should be six that's
a good idea
definitely a good idea a bishop is not a
good piece so trading it makes a lot of
sense okay so now he's got f5 lined up
and the way it is positioned right now
he does this move would help him lets
him
wenting G form as reprinting f4
Jim
hmm I really don't see much that I can
do here it's not very comfortable
you just sit sit down basically in your
position with white can I somehow prove
this I don't know it's very really not
great
maybe it's going G for now I'm not if I
can shut it down it's probably a draw
and have to be okay with the draw I
cannot really do anything here myself
yeah the system the ambitious move so
much stink
stay away from me too maybe now it's
time to finally play this Knight
maneuver okay he's got a taxi phone I
completely forgot about that
completely forgot about that
ouch what the heck is that
[Laughter]
Jesus what a game Wow
you know sometimes there are days where
you think okay I better not play any
game and let alone a bunch of blitz
games I mean our game was pretty awful
anyway but blundering this night like
that is great
okay so if I now take and go here next
smooth what happens okay I can take this
and take this
okay so I came to a draw
Wow that is extremely lucky I have
really really not happy with this game
yeah so here I don't know maybe I have
to keep the tension or something I
didn't want to move this again this
piece but yeah here this position is
really not offering me all that much
before I wanted to prevent 95 of course
but I'm weakening see for a lot just
like super solid I have played the black
side of those positions from the wrists
so often you just don't have any problem
get this traded I know f5s coming in
this is a good way of playing it take my
age was one thing that injured briefly
had in there I mean I think it's just an
equal position you know I think here we
had it must be equal 92 where but I'm
really going straight forward into this
into this problems here yeah I mean that
the CAPTCHA only makes sense that
connection to with what I did and what I
did was not good yeah otherwise
shouldn't just take 92 looks fine simply
I'm you know getting something like that
which is just a draw and now I'm really
no here I don't have a good move the
night is very annoying and a 4sv saw was
an issue to put it mildly quite
surprised that it is just
oh wow this is a cool resource this this
and this
Wow that's what I should do no and yeah
I just said I should just lose but he's
also human was 92 and he has okay
already I get rid of all the pawns just
um Oh 97 actually I can play for a win
funny funny funny funny but I was so
glad that I had a draw here they add
that that's dangerous he his pieces are
really not well positioned to the poor
near stopping the night and have easy
more skiing three nights is six and push
the pawns meaning it could be winning
could be winning here this is difficult
for like to play yeah many mistakes yeah
thanks for watching